now we turn our attention to the middle
east secretary of state tony blinken is
in the region trying to preserve a truce
between israel and hamas
he met with israel israel's prime
minister beckham netanyahu this morning
before going to the west bank to speak
with the palestinian president mahmoud
abbas blinken says he'll ask for
international aid
to help rebuild war-torn gaza where
holly williams is this morning
good morning the u.s put enormous
pressure on israel to call this
ceasefire
and secretary blinken's here to try to
make it stick
but expectations are low for what he can
actually achieve
that was driven home just now by prime
minister netanyahu when he said quote
if hamas breaks the calm and attacks
israel our response will be very
powerful
this is what secretary blinken had to
say as president biden has said
we believe that palestinians and
israelis equally deserve to live
safely and securely to enjoy equal
measures of freedom opportunity
and democracy to be treated with uh
dignity
here in the gaza strip they are still
counting their losses after a brutal
11-day conflict during which israel
pummeled gaza with blistering airstrikes
killing more than 250 according to
palestinian officials
including nearly 70 children and on the
other side
more than 4 000 rockets were launched
from gaza at israeli towns and cities
that was indiscriminate fire killing 13
civilians
the reality is that this ceasefire is a
band-aid because it doesn't address the
fundamental issue
which is two peoples who both believe
the same relatively small patch of land
is their homeland that's why we've seen
decades of violence erupting over
and over again holly williams reporting
from gaza